si tu as la vitesse ça va tourner tout
seul raconte encore
aller
micro et oreillette des échanges des
conseils en direct une technologie qui
facilite l'apprentissage du wakeboard
sorte de mode au ski nautique on peut
venir prendre des cours où on peut venir
tout simplement s'amuser est pratiquée
de façon loisirs mais quoi voir satar
niveau alors on prend tous niveaux on
prend tous niveaux du débutant au riders
confirmés allez vas-y fabrice vas-y
vas-y vas-y vas-y encore encore amateurs
de sensations fortes fabrice on est à sa
troisième leçon et il adore la pride est
assez vite on l'a la pédagogie avec le
casque et le micro bat isabelle nous
explique tout cas et
après on progresse on apprend des choses
de plus en plus compliqué
[Musique]
le concept était si basé sur une poulie
mobiles fixes et un câble de 260 m elle
permet de tracter le rider à 30 km heure
ou en douceur si nécessaire alors ça
c'est un système bi poulies donc c'est
un système qui se pilote avec deux
doigts donc le client otages il est très
très précis et on peut ajuster la
vitesse au niveau du raider est quand on
arrête le système le système ils
s'arrêtent instantanément n'y a pas une
inertie et comme sur un bateau ou alors
quand le rider tombe le bateau ou
continuer continuer là on arrête tout de
suite j'ai eu 14 ans pratique la
discipline depuis trois ans et réalise
déjà de nombreuses figures sur le
tremplin essayez ça enfin ça vaut
vraiment le coup
ses traits les sensations sont sont
fortes ses traits et l'activité est même
accessible dès l'âge de 3 ans si
l'enfant sait nager